[Música]
esse lugar é extraído a maior potência
que tem hoje inovação impacto
esse lugar é muito potente
ele é tão potente que nele eu conheci
várias pessoas que foram importantes na
minha vida que são de lá onde eu venho e
também com esse lugar que é muito
contente com esse pessoas que estão do
lado de cada ponte
se vocês me entendem nesse lugar
foi onde eu descobrir as verdadeiras
amizades as verdadeiras cumplicidades e
eu aprendi que inovação e impacto ela
nasce por uma necessidade na essência
desse lugar é da onde que a gente tira a
nossa base para fortalecer o nosso sonho
nesse lugar eu fui apresentado a cultura
hip hop
a música e nesse lugar
eu pude sair é o pt tem uma visão para
além do meu do meu bairro para além do
meu território através da música e da
cultura hip hop
isso fortaleceu minha raiz interior
fortalecer uma identidade não conseguia
ir e vir na quebrada e nessa quebrada
ela já foi um lugar muito cobiçado pelas
pessoas e pelas coisas negativas que
acontecia na década de 90 quando foi um
lugar mais bonito do mundo
se vocês não saibam jardim ângela já foi
o lugar mais violento do mundo e de si
um lugar que eu venho desse lugar que eu
juntei forças e conexões estratégicas
para viver do meu sonho ea partir daí
nasceu a banda para fazer eventos de hip
hop como moleque jovem querendo ir e vir
está ligado se conectar com as pessoas
e realizar o seu sonho realizar aqui no
que vem do coração
a inace a banca só para sobreviver na
quebrada sem pretensão nenhuma destrona
hoje uma produtora cultural social de
impacto que utiliza a música a cultura
hip hop educação popular ea tecnologia
para fortalecer o empreendedorismo
dentro das periferias e romper com as
barreiras culturais sociais conectando
as pessoas cruzando as pontes da cidade
nesse lugar a banca ela surgiu como uma
porta de saída dessa bolha da data
imposta
[Música]
aprendemos que as pessoas é a maior
tecnologia de conexão é de transformação
e começamos a cruzar os pontos da cidade
para romper com nossas barreiras romper
com nossos medos e mitos e falar com
essas pessoas do lado de cada ponte que
normalmente só tem um recorte da nossa
vida sobre o jornal e que é totalmente
distorcido não tem de fato uma visão e
uma vivência de como é viver de onde eu
venho e a gente usar as contas da cidade
foi revolucionário a gente sair da nossa
quebrada e vim pra cá porque como a
nossa periferia é muito potente
as pessoas do lado de cá da ponte elas
querem muito e até o lugar de onde eu
venho
tá certo que muitas vezes não têm a
troca muitas vezes cai no achismo de que
eu queria uma solução da hora que vai
selecionar a vida das pessoas que moram
na periferia
e aí gente tem uma coisa que é muito
importante saberem a a transformação só
acontece quando existe troca quando do
lado de cada ponte pessoas como vocês
querem até quebrada com uma
intencionalidade da hora positiva
a coisa só funciona quando tenha troca
não adianta achar que vai pra quebrar o
que vai salvar a molecada rapaziada de
lá não funciona eu gerei uma barreira
social
porque há 20 anos atrás as pessoas
vinham até o jardim ângela para colocá
los nas coisas negativas usava me usava
como um canal e não tinha troca
isso me encheram a banheira uma cicatriz
no qual não queria me relacionar e com
essa dor
a gente aprendeu que não precisa ser
assim se fosse assim eu já estava morto
já tinha feito um monte de coisas
erradas a banca não existia não
estaremos aqui com a banda origens
fazendo um som então desligou começamos
ponte
a banca é ponte a nossa dor ela
fortaleceu pretende se tornar se ponte e
usasse esse símbolo da ponte pra da
ponte pra cá como um caminho de troca
porque só funciona se houver troca só
funciona na hora que você estiver em ter
uma ideia inovadora para solucionar um
problema que eu vivo na pele em sala na
planilha financeira como a gente pode
estar junto
pensar na sua conexão estratégica nas no
seu network como a gente quer da
periferia pode participar desse processo
estamos cansados de ser visto como
clientes beneficiários e usuários
a periferia é potente olha que nunca
falei no começo né eu vim do lugar
potente e até hoje as pessoas ainda
acham que têm uma ideia inovadora dentro
do seu apartamento dentro do seu
escritório vai selecionar o meu problema
não vai porque não estou participando do
processo só vai dar certo se eu
participar do processo
então com essa vivência com esse
aprendizado percorrer nesse ecossistema
de negócios com impacto inovação a banca
artemis fgv empreendedorismo e novos
negócios se juntaram para que a anip que
é uma aceleradora de negócios de
impactos da periferia para colocar luz
em pessoas que estão e são das
periferias e aí eu posso trazer a
história de michelle empreendedora da
butique de crioula
ela vende acessórios para empoderar as
mulheres negras que estão nas bases está
ligada às mulheres violentadas
também posso fazer história do empreende
aí da gnr e do luís e são empreendedores
que estão fantasmas que fortaleceram a
base através de cursos ligados ao
empreendedorismo e tecnologia pode
trazer adriana barbosa que vocês todos
devem conhecer se não conhecer
faça o favor de conhecer porque ela é
referência no brasil diz tudo sobre raça
do público negro tá ligado que consome
que oferece serviços que são
empreendedores e aí eu posso trazer mais
um monte de gente que está na base da
pirâmide que está na periferia que está
fazendo inovação social
o impacto está ligado com
intencionalidade fortíssima porém com
agilidade financeira
então existe muito campo para que a
gente utilize as contas da cidade para
fazer essa conexão não acha que estando
do lado de cada cidade
a gente vai ter essa intensa esse
resultado de transformar a vida das
pessoas sem a conexão ea quebrada também
a gente tem que aprender a sair do nosso
território a cruzar as pontes e fazer
conexões que façam sentido para nossa
vida está ligado tirar os medos e mitos
da frente porque existe as bolhas dois
dos dois lados existe as bolhas dos dois
lados das pontos
então a gente pode fazer uma conexão
a gente pode ser a ponte porque a
periferia ela é o centro
ela é o centro da inovação da
transformação e da superação isso há
anos
nós estamos a banca
eu não estou sozinho estou com esse time
e convido vocês a virem até mim a
quebrar a tomar um café e trocar uma
idéia
obrigado
[Aplausos]